هل يشتري المال السعاده الاجابه نعم طبقا
للعلم على الاقل دراسه امريكيه جديده
نشرتها الاكاديميه الوطنيه للعلوم تحدد
درجات السعاده او سقف معين للسعاده البحث
الشمل اكثر من 33 الف شخص يعيشون في
الولايات المتحده ويحصلون على اجر سنوي
يعادل 10,000 دولار كحد ادنى كما هو متوقع
وجدت نتائجنا الشعور بالسعاده يواصل
الارتفاع كلما ارتفع الدخل لدى معظم الناس
لكن المثير الانتباهنا الباحثين لاحظوا ان
اقليه من المشاركين توقف ارتفاع معدل
شعورهم بالسعاده عندما وصلوا الى حد معين
من الدخل العالي طبق الاغلبيه على ان مئه
الف دولار سنويا يكفي للوصول الى سقف
السعاده واي زياده في الدخل بعدها لا تصنع
فارقا كبيرا
مزيد حول دراسه تجيب بكل بساطه ما الذي
يجعلنا سعداء مع علاء سرحان
في عام
1938 بدات جامعه هارفارد دراسه استقصائيه
لا تزال مستمره حتى اليوم بعد اكثر من
ثمانيه عقود والهدف الاجابه على سؤال يبدو
بسيطا ما الذي يجعلنا سعداء الدراسه تتبعت
نفس الافراد وعائلاتهم على مر السنوات
وطرحوا عليهم الاف الاسئله لاكتشاف ما
يجعل الحياه جميله بشكل عام
الدراسه نشرت نتائجها في كتاب صدر حديثا
بعنوان ذا جود لايف تبرز ان المال ليس
العنصر الاهم لتحقيق السعاده وانما
العلاقات والروابط البشريه هي التي تجعل
الناس اسعد لتاثيرها الايجابي على الصحه
البدنيه والعقليه وطول العمر المدير
الرابع للمشروع الذي قارب اليوم على قرن
قال ان السعاده ليست وجهه نصل اليها عندما
نشتري منزلا او نحصل على ترقيه انما
الصداقات والرفق العاطفيه وزملاء العمل
التي نبنيها على مر السنوات فالاشخاص مثلا
الذين كان لديهم روابط اجتماعيه اقوى في
مرحله الخمسينات كانوا في افضل حال عندما
وصلوا الى الثمانينات من عمرهم على كل حال
سالنا الناس هل المال يجلب السعاده ان
السعاده تجلب المال
السعاده علشان بالمال انا اقدر اشتري كل
حاجه انا عايزها يعني المال هو اللي بيجلب
السعاده علشان انقيس ان انت معك فلوس خلاص
بقى انت هتشتري بقى كل الحاجات اللي انت
عايزها مبسوط بقى وكده وممكن ابقى اساعدنا
مش لازم ممكن يبقى في حد في حياتي ويخليه
سعيد كلمه حلوه ممكن تخليني سعيد عشان انت
لو مش معاك فلوس هتبقى حزين فالفلوس هي
اللي بتقصر امال ما بيجربش السعاده نهائي
اه ممكن راحت البال والحاجات دي كلها هي
اللي تجلب الساعات يعني بس برضو مش هننكر
ان في يعني البني ادم اي بني ادم هيحتاج
المال السعاده اللي بتجلب المال
مبسوط وراضي باي حاجه في الدنيا
هيكرمه وهيرزقوه بالفلوس يعني المال كده
كده يعني يا فرحتي ان هيكون معايا فلوس بس
مثلا ما عنديش صحاب اهلي مش موجودين حياتي
مستعده مصرفها على العايه على اي حاجه فلا
طبعا السعاده هي اللي بتجلب المال انا
لازم اكون سعيده عشان اجيب المال واعرف
اشتغل واعرف استثمر اعمل اقتصاد وبكده
يجيني مات لو انا مش سعيده مش هحقق حاجه
[موسيقى]
العلماء اتفقوا ان المال يجلب السعاده هل
تتفق مع العلماء
نسبيا اه طبعا نسبيا المالحه مثلا انا
مقرر عندي اجازه في رمضان فحروح على دوله
حانزل على مصر وانبسط وغير جو ماخذ اجازه
55 يوم فلو انا ما معي المال اللي ممكن
اقطع فيه تذكره واللي يوصلني لهذا الهدف
قد اشعر بانه في شيء ناقص بس هنا الذكاء
عادي شوي اللي ممكن اعوض اني ما قدرت
اسافر
باشياء ترفيهيه اخرى ولكن بس طول ما كان
عندي انا مركز اني لازم انزل اجازه في هذه
الدوله والوضع المادي ما سمح لي ممكن
المال الان يؤثر على السعاده اللي انا كنت
متخيله انا حوصل لها طيب اذا عندما نقول
المال يجلب السعاده ما تعريف السعاده اصلا
تعريفها ما في حاجه نسبيه يعني هي السعاده
ممكن تكون انا نادر في انا احتضن مثلا
الطفل صغير عندي مثلا بنت صغيره البيبي
اول ما بنولدوا جميلين جدا وكذا فانا
بالنسبه لي ممكن في بعض الاحيان احتضن هذا
بيكون مصدر سعاده باور طاقه اي مسميات
كلها هذه اني بتفرج على اشي معين الكركر
او السعاده اللي احنا بنقولها مترجم من
كثر ما انت بتضحكي بتصيري تدمعي من عينك
او تصير تطلع من المعده فهي ممكن تكون
السعاده في واحد بقول لك اني اساعد الناس
مع احترامي للكل خلاص هذه سعادتك
فانا اللي بقرر هذا الشيء هو اللي بيسعدني
مش ما في مقياس زي جدول الضرب اني اقول لك
2 في 2 بيطلع اربعه
فكلتها نسبيه اضافه الى هذه المعايير
الظروف دكتور
ماذا تؤثر على استعادتنا كيف يمكن ان نكون
في مكان سعداء وفي مكان ثاني تعسى الحاله
التابعتي انا هي هادئه كلها ممكن نروح
نقعد على البحر
وكلنا نروح نقعد على البر انا بحب الاثنين
في ناس بتقول لك لا انا قعدت البر اللي هي
المقصود فيها الصحراء والرمال والهذه
الاشياء بقول لك لا انا بجيب الاكتئاب انا
بتضايق انا كذا طيب في ناس بنروح بقول لهم
طيب قعدت البحر كلها ممكن احنا الثلاثه
نروح او اربعه غيرنا اي اشخاص الروح كلها
نقعد في نفس الاماكن بس كل واحد ياخذ
خدمته الخاصه ويقعد على البحر كل واحد
حيكون قاعدته على البحر على حسب الحاله
الاجتماعيه تبعته على حسب المشكله
الاقتصاديه على حسب مشكله الشغل على حسب
كذا كذا انا ممكن اكثر واحد حتكون استرخاء
مش لاشي لاني خلاص انا اجازتي ابتدات خلال
اليومين هدول ممكن انا لو اخذتك او اخذت
اي حدا ثاني اه طب شو حاقعد ساعه ساعتين
لسه بدي ارجع البيت طب انا عندي بكره
الشغل طيب انا لسه مخدتش اجازه فهي انت
الحاله تبع المفروض يكون البحر مصدر سعاده
للجميع بس احنا الحاله اللي احنا رايحين
فيها هل انا مستعد فجاه اوديك على البحر
هلا يعني انا طب انا ما لابسه اواعي طب
لسه بدي اروح اجيب كذا فهي كلها على حسب
احنا كنا جاهزين الى المرحله هذه اللي
تكون فيها سعيدين زي الشخص السوري مع
احترامي للكل الفرح او العرس
الافراح المفروض تكوني تنبسط صح بس تخيل
ان انا واخد واحد مسكين لسه طالع من عمليه
او واحد كان عنده حاله وفاه هنا هذه
النقطه طيب لماذا انا املك المال الوفير
ولست سعيده اه هاي كارثه هذه كارثه عنا
اشخاص كتير موجودين عنا مع القصه انه بكون
عنده مال وفير بشكل غير طبيعي وشخصيات
مشهوره والناس ممكن يكونوا بيطلعوا معكم
في الاقتصاد وهو للاسف بيبدا يشك من كثر
كثره المال كل الناس اللي حواليا بتصاحبني
عشان اللي انت فهمتيه طيب في عندي حدا
ثاني ما شاء الله بيكونوا هم الاثنين
عايشين حياه زوجيه جدا ولكن ما عندهمش
قدره على الانجاب صرفوا فلوس فوق ما
تتخيلي وما قدروا هم ركزوا في انه مصدر
السعاده انه هو ينجب فهو طبعا لما فقد هذا
الشيء ما موجود فلذلك بالعكس في بعض
الاحيان ممكن يكون المال مصدر سعاده وقد
يكون المال مصدر تعاسه بيقولوا لي والله
ما بمزح بيقولوا لي تنحرق الفلوس كلها ما
بدي بس يكون عندي كذا عندي جنين او انا بس
انام وانا مرتاح بالليل لان خلاص كل الناس
اللي انا اعرفهم بيعرفوني بس عشان انا
اسمي كذا عشان فلوسي
ففي ناس بتحصل معاهم هيك ممكن يكون بالعكس
في بعض الاحيان المال مش مصدر سعد مصدر
تعاسه
شكرا جزيلا لك في الاستوديو حدثنا نادره
النفسي شكرا دكتور شكرا يا دكتور